smash your pass i'm going to do men in
the manosphere for you
oh god
okay
smash or pass um
myron
why is he always the first one
[ __ ] myron uh smash
um
would this happen though and probably
not
like you know what i mean
um
let's see
uh entrepreneurs and cars
who's that entrepreneurs and cars you
don't know who that is
google them oh she's back on access
you're okay you're okay okay hold on
entrepreneurs and cars
rich cooper yeah rich cooper
he looks like my ex dude
like hardcore so i guess smash
really yeah
type okay
like you have a very let's see smash
your pass
you'll never know my type because i
don't even know my type
um
the lead attorney do you look like again
the leader
um probably pass
pass
yeah pass
fresh
pass
which is funny because remember that one
time we played kill mary whatever
and i'm just like
smiling i guess
like at the time
women
well it's all about what the other two
they you put up you know i know i know
like that's not an absolute name i know
sometimes the red pill takes it so
seriously oh you're just like or just
doesn't get the actual video and thinks
that we actually want them all right
even oh my god
i could not believe when i saw the thing
that was like they're arguing about who
gets to f me i'm like that's how you
took the video well when somebody lives
in a delusion dude they make it fit your
narrative bro i was like
all the comments were like that's how
you took the video
i didn't even go back to the comments
since he deleted it he did yeah
i didn't know he deleted it that's even
better that's hilarious
yeah who else
donovan
smash
uh
you're just smashing everybody no i
passed on the last two fresh and lead
attorneys i know but for for the normal
girl like you're saying smash a lot more
than when i like talk to girls like it's
usually like 10 maybe 20
no i'm like aware of what i might say
versus what i might do so i try to go
based off of what i would do
huh
okay
um okay kevin samuels smashing pass i
can't stop staring at that piece of
artwork on his desk with all due respect
it's not good for add okay and don't
even listen to this man speak i look at
this
thing that goes back and forth then the
roll-up body
[Laughter]
i knew you were gonna i don't know why i
even asked that that was i don't know
either like he made my career
uh zooby
smash
i love him
[Music]
tuna okay thank you so much for the
super chat as you guys know all
donations are going towards the sound
board what am i doing with the sound
board okay
i'm going to get girls from all
different countries to come into my
apartment and we're going to talk about
different intersexual dynamics
so now i'm at 260 wait 367
out of my 500 goals
oh god no it would work that one woman
saved australia with
her nudes
[Laughter]
i think part of the reason that i dress
modestly is because i don't have the
confidence to like
to do it the other way
um pearl would you ever consider point
shaving
to help fund your youtube career what is
point shaving
it might be a brand
point i've had a few brands
reaching out and that sounds like
something they would say
yeah i don't know what that is well
donovan put it in the chat and i was
like i don't know what that means point
sharing
like point ship point shape i don't yeah
i don't know what that is
okay wait
um
okay what about o'shea duke jackson do
you know who that is yes
it sounds stupid
guys what is that guy's name um
i forget i always forget about sabo
well because i only know him through you
uh what about chisha do you know who
that is who
she should said
how do you it sounds like see it you
should
h i c h i s h a z e d
c h i
really
s h a z e d guys call in we'll rate you
smash your pass
shisha
said ah
i need more information
who is this man
he dislike i've been on his channel a
couple times oh he's really happy he's
really
i don't know i don't think he's a rapper
he's really nice hi
come on
he has an album
a rapper okay
oh i guess maybe he does all right
mediocre tutorials and reviews
is that a name
you don't know
you don't know who mtr is no he's got a
huge channel
you know this [ __ ] i don't know this
[ __ ] i'm tr
um mediocre
i don't know
pearl you have a youtube channel and you
don't know what point shaving is or
you're an athlete and you don't know
what point shaving is i don't know i'm
sorry
guys
all right google point shaving
an attempt as by member of the team
favor to win to influence the final
score of the game
oh so you pick somebody to win
so it's like a
i don't know okay but mediocre
what's the name
it says it means the game has been fixed
i don't know what that means um how
mediocre tutorials and reviews
john davis
uh oh i'd have seen this guy hold on
or maybe i haven't uh
pass
pass
pass
yeah did you
she
should smash your pass
uh
the the rapper dude that's all that yeah
yes
let me go back i have to look at him
again i think smash i'm not really into
i see
like i need to know who they are you
know
like what if i'm
a traitor
and by traitor i mean what if this is
somebody that like hates us
they're like you know like
oh i don't
like i mean hates like our channels or
something like somebody that makes
reviews or something like i don't know
well i don't i don't think he i don't
think he knows what our channels are i'm
going to be honest
has he talked about this
no i'm saying like i don't
call me that guy
had me on his channel i was like what do
you mean
like i was so scared and then i opened
it and he's giving me a curse
like this is something that would make
me not want to smash you you see what
i'm saying i think that would be a deal
that guy is so weird he follows me on
like different accounts and makes hate
videos and i'm just like give me more
attention
i mean like i don't know it's where
somebody into crystals or somebody that
like live streams
i don't know
zack you're gonna tell us what what
point shaving is
yeah i was surprised you didn't know
that because you used to play basketball
correct
yeah okay so you're aware that people
bet on games right
yeah typically not women's games but you
can't do a writing or anything on
youtube technically that's like yeah
basketball games this has nothing to do
with youtube well then
well donovan's comment was what i
consider point shaving for like the mic
so i was like i don't know what that
means
well okay let me explain well best i can
okay so people bet on the games and
sometimes people that bet on the games
they'll come up to a player and then be
like hey
i'll pay you x amount of money if you
underperform so i can so you can lose
this game so your team can lose
oh
would i do that um
at least i think that's what that was
going on there oh okay um it was a joke
i think okay yeah it looks like a joke
but
wait i don't get it i would just
you don't get it no
okay i'll explain again is this about
the sound board
yeah
i guess it could be it's just it's just
it's about money so i guess it's about
the sound board or whatever you want
he's asking if i would if i would throw
my games basically for money
like that's what he was asking like i
think he was kidding yeah i think that's
what i got from it yeah yeah
okay happy birthday
i appreciate it
um
but
anybody else in the youtube sphere is
that it
okay outside logan paul
uh pass
ksi
how the [ __ ] are these people dude you
don't know what ksi is he's no whatever
ksi
like i already know it's going to be a
rapper
it's a rapper no
no he's a youtuber he might rap too i
don't know but he's a youtuber
uh
pass
um
i might just be doing that because both
of them box
it could be a factor i dated a ufc
player
um andrew tate
andrew tate who the [ __ ] is that why
can't i think of that right now he's a
youtuber he's a youtuber
he just did a video the one with
michaela smash for sure
love him really
i like his vibe merch
dude i got so much hate on that video a
lot of people don't like him i didn't
know that oh because he's very
controversial
i feel like that i react to do a video
of him saying that he he throws a party
to how and cheats on his girlfriends in
front of each other and if if they're
not loyal to him
and he's like and if they're not loyal
then that's their fault
yeah like recently
[Laughter]
i mean
if you are
if you're you practice
you know maybe like islam
something in islam then
i don't think in islam i don't think in
islam they tell you to throw up party
well they believe in polygamy
yeah but not like that they believe in
wives not [ __ ] like right in front of
each other right like but he he
seriously is religious no
okay
that's what i've heard i don't know i
believe that just as much as i believe
michael is religious now
hasn't she always been
no
i thought she was that was what the
whole
how do you know
the video she found god at like 29.
did she i don't know yes that's like
that's why rolo made the video about her
because she found god at 29 so that's
why he was using the example
i thought he was using the example
because of uh leaving the baby daddy
well that too i didn't know there was a
god component i don't remember
uh chase elliott do you know who that is
no hold on i got my google up chase
the name sounds familiar elliott
nascar
or youtuber
um
yes
daniel cormier
how do you spell the last name
c-o-r-m-i-e-r
if i drop a 500 super chat will i date
you
what it
got 1300
i'm not a prostitute no i love when
people would be annoying at the bar and
i'd be like okay 1300 for my troubles
and they would
it's great
it doesn't hurt to ask guys call in call
in
and we will rate you
smash your pass so the dean from last
show that the first guy
um
that you get you said pass or smash and
i said pass because of the weight he's
working out
actually i think he sent me i was like
we want to update pictures i told him
he's getting back on in a month a month
and we're going to see if the score goes
up
oh my gosh that's so funny
did i not tell you that i told somebody
no you didn't tell me that did you tell
him i smashed him
on
i honestly i didn't say this but i think
you guys are gonna end up together i see
it
you see it yeah okay so
he was like hey it's dean hi dean by the
way he goes i really enjoyed being on
the show
a couple days ago he sent me this on
saturday um i think i really wanted to
underestimate how much my weight was
holding me back i set my intake for
losing two pounds a week
um on lose it thanks for the honesty it
got me off my ass and starting the
process and i'm just thinking to myself
this is why i love men because you guys
have this thing this software heart
hardware whatever you want to call it
where if you post something as a
challenge as in
having to get laid
like going to the gym to get rid of your
man boobs is a lot more like that hits
closer than lose the weight right yeah
like because you want to have sex
and not have man boobs so like the thing
about men is you pose anything as a
challenge
and like as long as they've been in the
habit of some of something it could be
anything like work
they have it in them to like jump on
that like we don't really have that at
least because we get we get hurt we're
like ah
like if somebody said you're a four
because you're too fat like
we cry
right but they listen they say oh i can
be a nine if i just lose the weight
that's it like yeah yeah and
i'm i'm like oh let's make this a
challenge again so then i'm like come
back in a month
see if your score goes up because he was
good looking dude he had the job
that's what i said i was like like it's
literally just your way to be honest
i wouldn't look at him because of the
weight though and i'm not talking about
him as a person i want to be clear i'm
just saying when somebody is overweight
the reason i've never had really guys
that were overweight ask me is because
they're invisible to me the only reason
why i was like even looking at him was
because he called in and i bet you a lot
of women are like that i just want
it's like come on you got it all
now allocated in all areas
yeah and that's the one thing you can
change like he had a good face like you
could tell he was cute oh yeah
it was just
literally the weight
and i was like even if he just got to
like 200 like 220 that would probably be
fine what's he yeah do you remember it
was like close i think it was over 300
to be honest i did that might have been
me saints the new producer on freshman
fix i remember saying that he was at 397
and he's like working with uh myron he's
so he's so sweet you would be obsessed
with this guy
he's like smiling all the time totally
your type like positive
i see it
i don't know
wait who
new producer like another producer on
freshman i glanced at it like it was
it popped up while i was uploading a
video and then i was like oh who's this
guy and he was introducing himself but
he was at 397 so i'm curious to see
his weight loss journey they're going to
check in like every week
huh
oh that's so cute actually
yeah like that'll be cute though to like
to have him come back like that's
adorable oh hell yeah
it's like you better get your ass in the
gym dean we're going to be watching no i
mean
that's what i always say when you get
rejected it's all about how you respond
it is all about how you respond because
like the way he responded and he wasn't
like butt hurt yeah like it makes you
more attracted to to the guy same with
the one who i was like oh you're too
short for me but you're still like
you're cute you're too short
was it james i think it was james i'm
not a names person
because you don't care
there's a video on it that came off rude
there's a whole uh what's that one
youtube channel called like mindset
something about
with tom billio
quest bar guy
you know who i'm talking about stop
his sister has a channel and she
interviewed somebody who what's her name
quest what is it what do i have to
google tom billy tom b.i he talked to
michaela on that
episode where she was talking about her
daughter
remember yeah yeah